- Oh.
(cheering)
There he is.
What's up Noah?
Michael Jackson.
No.
(sharp screems)
That's what he does.
That's Michael Jackson.
(soft rock music)
(bell buzzing)
Lil Wayne y'all.
The Carter.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm coming to y'all straight
from Rikers Penitentiary beds,
Y'all heard me.
Haters out there
think I'm playing.
Think I'm some kind of joke man.
Young Money.
Check this out right here, man.
(mumbles)
I'm the baddest (beep) on
his whole prison here bitch.
You heard, check
it out, let's go.
I'm the baddest dude...
(yelling)
(bell buzzing)
Lil Wayne y'all.
Young Money.
(upbeat music)
Yáll need to watch
your back, you heard?
That's right, yeah, yeah,
'cause I'm coming for y'all.
What's up man, I run this y'all.
In fact y'all let's go.
I'm the baddest,
where you going man?
Where are you going?
Hey man, where you going?
You ain't gotta go.
(yelling)
Okay, I see pick on
the little guy, huh?
Punks, you hate.
(yelling)
It's ironic, come
on men right here.
(bell buzzing)
(upbeat music)
I'm not supposed to be
doing this right now man.
Young Money.
(indistinct)
(upbeat music)
Man, I ain't even scared, yo.
(shower splashing)
- This is (indistinct)
I have been babysitting for
20 years, I've seen it all.
- The thing is
Forest is a unique child.
- Everything is gonna be fine.
I want you to have a good
time tonight, you deserve it.
- Okay,
good luck.
- Thank you.
(soft music)
(mumbles)
Hey there, Forest.
- Gugu gaga,
I want milk.
- You want me to get
your bottle buddy?
- I want milk.
- Okay.
- This is a Baba
I want mama's milk.
I cannot have mama's milk.
It's a simple request.
- Yeah, well you can't have
mama's milk right now, buddy.
How about we play?
- Okay.
I want to play with my legos.
- Okay, yeah.
Okay buddy, let's
get your legos done.
- I want to put the
smallest lego in my mouth.
That's what I'm gonna do.
- No, no, no, you can't do that.
- First, you tell me
I can momma's milk.
Now, you have a small
lego in my mouth?
What a night?
This is a bad start.
- Forest, it's dangerous.
- Let me get this straight.
You're in charge
of me in my house?
- Forest, it's time for bed.
- I guess then,
you gonna sing me a song.
- What?
- Mama always sing me a
song before I go to sleep.
Are you gonna do that for me.
- Okay, okay, yeah, yes, I will.
♪ Hush little baby
don't say a word. ♪
- Keep, keep singing.
♪ Momma's gonna buy
you a mocking bird. ♪
- Put my name in there.
I like it personal.
♪ Hush baby Forest Whitaker,
don't say a word. ♪
- Gugu gaga.
♪ Momma's gonna buy
you a mocking bird. ♪
- Good babysitter.
♪ And if that mocking
bird don't sing. ♪
- Have a good cry.
(crying)
- Hey, babe.
- Hi.
- I made a really big decision
without consulting you.
I went by puppy rescue
stand on university avenue.
I had to.
- You got us a dog?
- Yeah, I did.
(indistinct)
So honey, I've got to
tell you something, okay?
These rescue dogs have
had some tough situations
and a lot of them take on the
personality of their owners.
This dog was owned
by rapper Ice Tea.
All right, little
buddy, come on.
- Hello my little darling.
- Ma'am, (beep) you.
You, suck my (beep)
This house ain't (beep)
- Okay buddy, take it easy.
(indistinct)
- Nothing ever been
easy for me in my life.
Now, hook me up with a treat.
- You want a treat buddy?
- You want to treat.
- Yeah, that's a taste
ass treat right there.
Now give me the whole bag.
- Okay, one treat is enough.
- Bitch, was I talking to you?
Give me the whole bag of treats
'cause I'm a treat killer
and a mother (beep) handful.
- Somebody is crappy today.
- Meet my ass right upon
this comfortable ass sofa.
I'm gonna sleep on this bitch
too as a matter of fact.
You know what mother (beep)
and bitch I'm gonna
piss up here too.
- Oh, no, no, no, no.
Raise your hand at me?
- Okay, I've got something
for you little guy, huh?
- You wanna play fetch?
You like fetch?
- Get that ball.
- (beep) you, both y'all
condescending mother (beep)
I ain't your
entertainment bitch.
(beep) you.
(door bell ringing)
- Oh, hello, who is this?
- Come on Coco, don't worry
about the mother (beep)
That's my bitch, Coco.
Or I forgot to tell y'all she
going to be living here too.
- Wow, okay, you got
your little friend here?
Well, she can play
here for a while.
- Puppy play day.
- Yeah.
- Play day, we gonna
have a (beep) date.
That's what we gonna have bitch.
Come here bitch.
- Okay, he's doing that.
Oh no, don't do that.
Oh, that's my shit too.
- Okay, oh dear.
- Get the (beep) out of here,
it's about to get
graphic in this bitch.
How come you don't
do that with me?
- I told you.
- He does it.
- I just wanna keep
this area clean.
- Here we go, we got more.
(all cheering)
- Come on in, yes.
- All right.
- Thanks for coming.
(all laughing)
Have a bloody good time.
- Awesome.
- Oh.
(cheering)
There he is, what's up Noah?
Michael Jackson.
(cheering)
That's what he does.
That's Michael Jackson.
(cheering)
Nice.
- Shamone.
- Oh, there we go.
(cheering)
There we go.
All right, three of Shamone.
Four, all right.
- Well Annie, are you okay?
- Oh, he's leaning.
He's leaning.
Are you okay Annie?
Are you okay?
Andy, are you okay Annie?
You've been touched
by a smooth criminal.
Shamone.
- More kicks.
- Closer, close to your face.
- You almost hit me there.
(indistinct)
- You wanna come inside?
That's annoying.
That is very
annoying, stop, stop.
Don't do it anymore.
Great.
- Shamone.
- Just keep doing that Shamone.
That's where the children act.
(indistinct)
- This isn't,
don't even know what that is.
- Real eyes.
Shamone.
What are you doing?
(indistinct)
No, you cutoff for Shamone.
- Oh, okay.
- He doesn't slap
his ass like that.
So I don't know what.
(indistinct)
He doesn't, I've never
seen him hit his ass.
(yelling)
Can we just,
Hey, stop it, stop it, stop it.
The (beep) costume
is awfully impression
of stupid and played out.
Everybody and their mother
was Michael Jackson three
years ago when he died.
(crowd noise)
- He died?
- Oh.
- Wait, wait, he died.
- Oh, Noah.
Oh Noah.
No, wait a second.
Don't suddenly walk away.
(yelling)
Happy Halloween.
(bright upbeat music)
- Nobody likes you you girl.
Well, you're a different
color than me and that's bad.
- Oh yeah, when
you dress like a...
- Now hold on a second.
- [All] Whoa, Mr. T.
Never make fun of a
way a man dresses.
A way a man dresses
is his business.
Remember that,
whether it was overall,
chains or feather earings,
however they dress, it's
not to be joked about.
I pity the fool that judges
another man's clothing.
- I'm sorry I judged
your clothing.
- It's okay.
(bright upbeat music)
- Hey Scout, there's
a man over there,
who said he'll give us
candy if we get in his van.
- I don't know if that's
a good idea to me.
- What are you afraid of?
Is it because you have a
stupid name like Scout?
- Hey.
- Whoa, Mr. T again.
- Never make fun
of a person's name.
Your mama gave you that name
or you made it up for
business purposes.
Either way, it's personal.
I pity the fool to make
fun of another man's name.
Mr. T is a cool name.
It's a cool name, Mr. T.
(upbeat music)
- Hey Scout, wanna
do some drugs?
- Aren't drugs bad?
- I don't know.
If you're afraid of drugs,
we could drink a
bunch of alcohol.
- Yeah, that sounds good.
- Well, guess what?
Your hair is stupid.
- Never make fun of
another person's hair.
- [All] Hey, Mr. T .
- A person's hair is the artwork
that they present
to the heavens.
It's just like,
I've been saying.
(soft rock music)
♪ It isn't fair ♪
♪ Beware ♪
♪ People care about their hair ♪
♪ H is for the home
where I lay my head ♪
♪ And I cry about your
mean jokes in my bed ♪
♪ A is for anxiety these
are fools provoked ♪
♪ When they're looking at my
hair and they making jokes ♪
♪ I is for I don't
like the way I feel ♪
♪ when you're joking that my
hair cause it does not appeal ♪
♪ R is for the real
mean jokes you make ♪
♪ And the hurtful little
part shots that you take ♪
And for your information,
it's not even a haircut.
It's a rare form of
male pattern baldness.
You fools.
(crying)
For real.
(upbeat music)
- Good evening my
fellow Americans.
Now, before I begin,
I just wanna say that I know
a lot of people out there
seem to think that
I don't get angry.
That's just not true.
I get angry a lot.
It's just the way I express
passion is different from most.
So just so there's
no more confusion,
we've hired Luther here to be
my anger translator, Luther.
- Hi.
- First off,
concerning the
recent developments
in the middle Eastern region.
I just wanna reiterate
our unflinching
support for all people
and the right to a
democratic process.
- Hey, all y'all
dictators out there,
keep messing around
and see what happens.
Just see what happens, watch.
- Also, to the governments
of Iran and North Korea,
we once again are
due to discontinue
your uranium enrichment program.
- Hey Mahmoud, Kim Jong,
I think I told both
y'all 86 (beep) bitches,
I'm gonna come over
there and do a for y'all.
Please test me and
see what happens.
- On the domestic front.
I just wanna say to my
critics, I hear your voices
and I'm aware of your concerns.
- So maybe if you can chill
the hell out for like a second,
then maybe I can focus
on some (beep) you know.
- And that goes for everybody,
including members
of the (indistinct)
- Oh, don't even get me started
on these (beep) right here.
- I wanna assure you
that we will be looking for
new compromises with the GOP
in the months ahead.
- And you know these (beep)
will say no before you can see.
- Now I know a lot of folks say
that I haven't done a good job
at communicating my
accomplishments to the public.
- Because y'all
(beep) don't listen.
- Since being in office, we've
created 3 million new jobs.
- 3 million new jobs.
- We ended the war in Iraq.
- Ended the war, y'all, we
ended a war, remember that?
- These achievements
should serve as a reminder
that I am on your side.
- I am not a Muslim.
- And that my intentions
as your president
are coming from the right place.
- They're coming from Hawaii,
which is where I'm from,
which is in United States
of America, y'all, okay?
This is ridiculous.
I have a birth certificate.
I have a (indistinct)
birth certificate
yet damn ass...
- Okay, Luther,
(indistinct)
- Luther damn.
- In conclusion,
last night, I had a
conversation with Michelle.
(indistinct)
Nope, I did not say that.
I did not say that.
(soft rock music)
♪ Well, tonight we gonna party
'til the party don't stop ♪
♪ And the party don't stop
because it keeps on going ♪
♪ Non-stop, gonna
party all night ♪
♪ Gonna keep this party going ♪
♪ Coz the party won't stop ♪
♪ It's been two straight days
and the party's still going ♪
♪ 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7 days ♪
♪ 'Til it's Friday again
and the party keeps going ♪
♪ Party all night coz
it's an all-night party ♪
♪ Friday night, 9 PM ♪
♪ Hop in the car,
call my friends ♪
♪ Drinks in the back,
girls out front ♪
♪ Going to a party,
sending texts ♪
♪ Cell phone rings,
iPad, Facebook ♪
♪ Party time, skin-tight jeans ♪
♪ Friday night,
dance dance dance ♪
♪ Coz tonight we going out
and we ain't coming back ♪
♪ Coz the party won't stop,
it will go all night ♪
♪ Friday night every night ♪
♪ The party's going down ♪
♪ Down, down, down, down,
down, down, down, down, down ♪
♪ New York City, LA, Chicago ♪
♪ Houston, Philly, San Diego ♪
♪ Phoenix, Boston,
Fort Worth, Austin ♪
♪ Memphis, Denver,
Portland, Vegas ♪
♪ Tucson, Fresno, Akron, Tampa ♪
♪ Pittsburgh, Newark,
Plano, Lincoln ♪
♪ Lubbock, Durham,
Salem, Dayton ♪
♪ City, city, city, city ♪
♪ Coz tonight we going out
and we ain't coming back ♪
♪ Coz the party won't stop,
it will go all night ♪
♪ Friday night every night ♪
♪ The party's going down ♪
♪ Down, down, down, down,
down, down, down, down, down ♪
♪ New York City, LA, Chicago ♪
♪ Houston, Philly, San Diego ♪
♪ Phoenix, Boston,
Fort Worth, Austin ♪
♪ Memphis, Denver,
Portland, Vegas ♪
♪ Tucson, Fresno, Akron, Tampa ♪
♪ Pittsburgh, Newark,
Plano, Lincoln ♪
♪ Lubbock, Durham,
Salem, Dayton ♪
♪ City, city, city,
city, cities ♪
♪ Now we're gonna
keep it going ♪
♪ to the break of,
break of dawn ♪
♪ Then we'll just keep
partying all day long ♪
♪ Hot girls, music, dancing
and bikinis and headphones ♪
♪ Party, party, party, party,
party, party, party, party ♪
(gun shot)
(soft rock music)
♪ So tonight we gonna party
'til the party don't stop ♪
- Who are you gonna call?
(laughing)
Hi, I'm Ray Parker Junior,
writer and performer of
the Academy Award nominated
hit single Ghostbusters,
from the major motion
picture Ghostbusters,
but that's just one song.
I've written so many other
major motion picture theme songs
and submitted them
throughout the year.
Now they're available
and together for
once specially price,
copulation songs like,
♪ You tried to play the game
but it's driving you insane. ♪
♪ Jumanji ♪
♪ Danger in the jungle ♪
♪ This line in my house. ♪
♪ Come on, Mr. Computer,
throw me a bone ♪
♪ I said, no, mower man ♪
♪ Get up off my lawn ♪
♪ When Armageddon is near ♪
♪ You better get out of here ♪
♪ Looking like (indistinct) ♪
It's getting legal y'all.
These songs have only been
heard by the highest level
of industry
decision-makers but now you
can feel like a Hollywood
executive in your own home.
♪ I see your face off ♪
♪ That guy walking around ♪
♪ It's a face off ♪
♪ That ain't even your face ♪
(indistinct)
♪ You know my daddy
is the boss. ♪
♪ That is not even a word ♪
♪ Now, there's a
whole lot of kinky ♪
♪ That room is stinky. ♪
♪ 50 Shades of Gray ♪
♪ All right white people ♪
♪ Who's a slave ♪
♪ I'm not a slave oh, oh ♪
♪ 12 years a slave ♪
There's one thing I know,
is that persistence
makes perfection.
So Hollywood missed out.
But that doesn't
mean you have to.
Down ain't enough
basement, what's going on?
(indistinct)
(soft music)
Order now,
to receive your
free copy of Bobby,
sings the two theme songs to
sequels that were never made.
- Call my agent.
(phone ringing)
- Jen Pickett Smith, my man.
- What's up Clyde,
hey look, man, I'm gonna
be real with you, okay?
This alien boy script,
I'm not feeling it.
I mean, it's hard
being Will Smith son.
I just wanna make
sure my next project
reflects I'm a down
to earth normal kid.
Am I making any sense?
- Yeah, I'm reading
you loud and clear.
I've got a script right here.
Very real called Street Ball.
- Talk to me.
- Okay, so you play Tony.
He's a kid from the
streets, lives in the hood,
in a house with his mom.
- Stop.
- House?
- Oh, it's like a tiny mansion.
- Got it, go on.
- So his mom and he,
they live in this house and
she works at a supermarket.
- Stop.
- Oh, supermarkets,
like a mansion,
but it's full of food
and anyone can go there.
- So like where the butlers go?
- Yeah, basically so he...
- And wait, you said his mom
was doing something
at the supermarket?
- Working.
- So...
- Working as kind of like
acting on a set every day
in a film that no
one's ever gonna see
and it lasts for the
rest of your life.
- Oh, like a maid.
- Yeah, yeah, she's like
the maid of a supermarket.
- Awesome, continue.
- So anyway, Tony doesn't make
the basketball team, right?
So he decides to start
playing pickup games
of street ball outside.
- So he plays
basketball on his plane?
- No, on the ground.
- In his limo?
- Outside is that
stuff that goes by
when you're inside the limo.
- Oh snap, he plays basketball
outside of the limo door?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So then he gets really
good at basketball
and then blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah, fast forward
at the heart of the story,
Tony has to choose
between his mom...
- Choose.
- Yeah, choose is when you
have to make a decision
between two things you want
but you can have only one.
- But
there's two.
- Yeah, but I mean,
he can't have both.
- What I say about
science fiction Clyde?
It's a no.
- Okay, we'll pass.
(Clyde sneezing)
- Dad, bless you.
- Thanks
- Ladies and gentlemen,
Darrius Rucker.
(audience cheering)
(guitar music)
♪ Don't wanna wake
my friends no more ♪
♪ Don't wanna hold
your hand no more ♪
♪ I don't wanna be with you. ♪
- [Crowd] Hootie,
Hootie, Hootie, Hootie...
- Oh no.
Nah, nah, nah.
I'm not in Hootie and the
Blowfish anymore y'all.
Doing my own thing.
- What do you mean in Hootie?
Because you, you
are Hootie, man.
Come on everybody
- [Crowd] Hootie,
Hootie, Hootie, Hootie...
- All right, no, no,
no, stop it, stop it.
I'm not Hoodie, I'm
Darrius Rucker, all right?
I used to be the front man
for a band Hootie and
the Blowfish, all right?
But I was never Hootie.
There was never a Hootie.
- Just if I may ask,
where are the Blowfish at?
Right guys?
Come on everybody, Blowfish.
- [Crowd] Blowfish,
Blowfish, Blowfish...
- Oh, no, no, no,
there are no people
known as the
Blowfish y'all, okay?
The whole band was just called
Hootie and the Blowfish.
That's it.
It was a nonsense name,
like who was that or
Told The West Pocket.
- Oh.
(guitar music)
♪ No going out with
my friends no more ♪
♪ Don't wanna hold
your hand no more ♪
(indistinct)
- I see, I get it
now, I understand.
Hey, we gotta pick y'all..
We gotta choose between
Hootie or the Blowfish.
So who wants to
see the Blowfish?
(crowd cheering)
- There's no Blowfish.
- And who wants to see Hootie?
- Hey, that hurts
my feelings y'all.
- But you said you
weren't Hootie?
- No, I'm not, sir.
But in the question you
just asked the audience,
I was clearly Hootie.
So you are Hootie?
I'm not though.
- He is Hootie.
(crowd cheering)
- [Crowd] Hootie, Hootie,
Hootie, Hootie, Hootie...
(crowd cheering)
(sharp cheering noise)
(audience clapping)
- Now ladies and gentlemen,
the man you've been waiting
for Mr. Michael Winslow.
Go get them Winslow.
(audience cheering)
Bring the noise.
Another sold out night for
the Kings of mouth noise.
I tell you though,
we wouldn't have this
audience without Winslow.
Lucky for you, huh?
This police academy fans.
Look at all the T-shirts.
Six sequels, can you believe it?
Every sound effect
this guy makes
is like a little tiny Mona
Lisa popping out of his mouth
Have you ever heard him do
the walking through
leaves in the fall?
(intense upbeat music)
(door banging)
(shouting)